we had other visual media services
directive on level of progress report
decision European year of cultural
heritage general approach we had very
interesting policy debate about strategy
for international cultural relations and
of course decision about European
capitals of culture for the years 20 22
2033 general approach he taking a
location in dolman him all the
technological change and development in
the audiovisual sector are so speedy
that consultation has been the de fruit
meant that if we want to keep a European
authority than we have to cover the
ground and make achievements we had a
very fruitful discussion on the
Commission's proposal to make 2080 in
the European year of cultural heritage
this is a key step that I hope we paved
the way for a swift adoption by the
council and the European Parliament it
shows that Minister share the European
Commission's view and the importance of
transmitting our heritage to future
generations as a source of identity and
a valuable resource for economy growth
employment and social cohesion